one of the biggest sporting events on
Earth teams representing 32 Nations will
begin play tomorrow in the World Cup the
global soccer tournament held once every
four years for the first time ever it
will be played in the Middle East in the
tiny nation of Qatar but as Roxanna
Siberia reports the organizers of these
games are facing a world of scrutiny
with its seven new sparkling stadiums
the tiny shakedum of gatar is poised to
kick off the world's top soccer
tournament this weekend making a
comeback the U.S team it failed to even
qualify four years ago with an average
age of 25 and a half it's now one of the
youngest of the 32 squads at age 28
goalkeeper Matt Turner is an elder does
that youth help or hurt the team with
it's not just necessarily the age but
it's the mentality of the people that we
have in the locker room that really want
to make their Mark and are eager to you
know
compete and win and change the way the
World Views soccer in America 17 of them
including star forward Christian pulisic
and midfielder Gio Reyna play in
European leagues but only one has
experienced a World Cup
this tournament caps over a decade of
controversy over whether wealthy Qatar
bribed its way into winning the
prestigious hosting gig and over the
treatment of Migrant workers who toiled
in The Soaring heat to build new
infrastructure often living in squalid
camps like this
I have heard several fans tell me
including in the United States that they
are boycotting This World Cup because of
qatar's Human Rights record and I
respect that journalist Grant Wall has
covered 13 World Cups so far but none
like this one Qatar certainly seems like
it's ready to host this tournament
because the stadiums were done many
months ago they're beautiful they've
built an entire city out of what was
desert just a few years ago it's the
smallest country to host a World Cup and
the first Muslim one just yesterday
gatori authorities suddenly reversed a
decision that would have allowed
Budweiser to sell beer within Stadium
perimeters before and after games the
multi-million dollar sponsor still plans
to sell alcohol and official fan zones
but away from the action then there is
the issue of same-sex relationships
which are deemed illegal here even
punishable with the death penalty but
organizers say everyone is welcome at
the tournament
FIFA's president has called on all the
teams to focus on the sport but the U.S
team is taking a stance in some ways
like with this rainbow-themed logo on
its training grounds in solidarity with
the lgbtq community we recognize that
Qatar has made strides and there has
been a ton of progress but there's still
some some work to do proceed for CS
morning Saturday I'm Roxanna saberi Doha
you know cutter did a huge publicity
campaign to sort of like raise
the hype of this event it's interesting
to see how much of an impact that might
have had on folks going over despite all
of this well and I think it's everybody
people love soccer it's sort of trying
to come to terms with all the other
issues that Roxanna mentioned and say I
love soccer but I'm trying to deal with
all this first match is tomorrow and
then the U.S plays for their first match
against Wales right yeah it's like Wales
and then England Wales one of the
favorite
teams